like doing other hey folks welcome to
now playing on gamespot.com or
twitch.tv/ Gamespot wherever you are
we're glad to have you I'm Chris Waters
joined by Aaron Samson how's it going
and we are playing some Titanfall DLC
the first the Expedition DLC has dropped
this morning like uh 3 hours ago or
something like that so we've just got it
downloaded got a few matches under
Aaron's belt this will be my first but
we're going to play through some of the
maps and uh talk to talk about the patch
notes and all that stuff and see what's
new here in uh the Titanfall DLC so
let's go ahead and uh see what's what
we're playing on the map runoff
currently Aaron and uh this place is
like a real crap area for you know uh
Industrial Waste one of the first things
I've noticed with Expedition DLC so far
is these maps are pretty big um I was
particularly surprised by swamp lands
which we'll just affectionately call
Endor oh yeah it's really nice that
thing is huge me come on there's
definitely ewoks in that situation we've
been enjoying last Titan standing
matches on that
map um some other cool additions uh to
this DLC I already deployed them are uh
you can now have customizable Loadout
slots um for different modes yeah so
well like that's even you know that's
with the little latest patch right so
there's two things you can have the DLC
which is the three new maps but everyone
playing is going to be playing with the
new patch and one of those things is in
addition to your five pilot loadouts and
five uh oh that's not a permeable cover
surface so you know you can have your uh
your last Titan standing you're coming
with me class you can have your Capture
the Flag sneaky sneaks class mhm um you
know you just you can finally name them
so you actually you know remember which
is which
yeah so that and those things you you
unlock the ability to do that once
you've like uh played a couple matches
in a given match type and uh those offer
a nice degree of sort of specialization
right oh oh I almost got that enemy
Titan see if I can get in there uh so
like for example I really don't like the
light machine gun but the slammer
attachment is really good for like when
you Rodeo a Titan and want to destroy it
uh so you know if I put that in a last
Titan
standing load out then uh then I'm
digging it then it's all good I'll come
back I can get this guy to go to my
mines
no oh you're getting it I'm also getting
it uh it's it's three Maps but they're
fairly I mean from what we've seen
they're fairly expensive large Maps no
you are not going to Nuke eject me yeah
so for example here we are on runoff oh
gosh not going to get me with your
central charge so I'm out of here see
you later uh there's a quick little
aerial view it depends I I can't
actually see which view you folks are
seeing uh cuz there's a monitor in the
way but you just saw me get stepped on
uh Samson and I are both playing on PC
he's playing with a control or he's
playing with the keyboard mous mouse and
keyboard I'm playing with a controller
as uh I prefer to do call me crazy if
you
will and I'm gonna shoot you with a the
chances I can drop a Titan on this guy
oh he saw me he saw me drop a Titan on
his Titan there you go so Titan dropping
that's another thing that's gotten a
couple changes uh you can no longer drop
a Titan on a drop ship apparently that
was not intended you also have more
protection within your bubble Shield or
your Dome Shield when you drop your
Titan you can't get um empd the way you
could before uh-huh yeah you can't so
like like you'll
be you'll be safe from getting empd oh
gosh boom Oh gosh we got to get out of
here no
ah your Dome Shield they sort of amp
that up a little bit so for example you
can't get punched out of your Dome
Shield your auto Titan if it goes after
an enemy uh it will
not it won't it won't like go into their
Dome shield and get itself damaged yeah
so you can't you can't hurt them while
they're in their D Shield they also like
in recent patches they increased the
protection of the uh Dome shield for
Pilots that are rodeoing friendly Titans
so you're more protected from explosions
now than you were before like but that
is that doome Shield specifically you're
talking about or is that just the Titan
sheld no that's just the Titan Shield
okay so you know you you were previously
afforded some protection as a pilot when
you're friendly rodeoing if the Titan
you were on has Shields yeah they've now
increase that protection against
explosive damage um that came up in a
recent patch which is pretty nice we've
got the patch notes here we're checking
it out and uh we're also taking a look
at what you guys are saying in the uh
twitch chat and taking your questions
and stuff like that for example Matt
Smith 83 yes I do play with inverted
controls because that is the right and
true sensible way to use a controller
hey we recently did a piece called
Return of the space and we were talking
about how like an entire generation of
Gamers who grew up playing X-Wing are
inverted because of it yeah still inted
yeah those like six degrees of freedom
the joystick space flight leaning
forward just that's looking down to me
and pulling back is looking up so that
translated to my uh so check it out uh
over here I've got this pointed out so
uh this is my last Titan standing load
out I got my you're coming with me y
That's a good one load out uh Capture
the Flag very important I got my flag
attacker and my flag Defender which for
me it varies with shotgun and mines um
and then so you you can you can cycle
your loadouts here and and add them in
now I'm pretty sure I think a lot of
this stuff is being released for
everybody I think it's just the maps or
the DLC but a lot of these updates you
don't have to pay for yeah they're just
the free update to the uh to the game
that you will probably have to
automatically download when you log in
it's about a gab oh I should have got
also as a general note if you're not
playing three burn cards around which I
forgot to like load up my burn cards but
you are not playing to your full
potential because especially in a game
like capture the flag you can drop that
Strider right away you can make an
immediate flag cap if you've got the
like the permanent stem or the permanent
speed boost you're going to be outr
running Titans with the flag so you know
people who have not played this game a
lot spend your burn cards every match
yeah man you earn them pretty quickly
anyway so uh but currently the twitch
the chat at twitch.tv/ GameSpot is a
flame with inverted versus non-inverted
I love it when people myself included
try to like logically explain it like oh
it just makes sense to do it that
way it's not a sense thing people aren't
like oh yes this is the most reasonable
way for me to play I very I shall choose
it it's more akin to left-handed versus
right-handed people yeah I know I think
it's something that some game or some
experience you have when you're younger
and you're gaming uh sort of sets you on
a path and then everything else feels
super weird I mean if you're Lefty you
could learn to be a righty technically
mhm you're never going to be as good are
you and be dextrous is totally a
thing be quiet all right so I'm going to
roll with my flag
attacker uh we are currently playing on
Swamp land which we are changing the
name to Endor cuz this is totally Endor
oh get I want to go on this look how
like the zip line goes across the entire
map I want to call this thing too this
might actually be a good Zippity
Zippity you can make it between trees
it's so
good all right Samson I'm coming in on
the flag are these Pilots
no oh I got jump kicked that was so lame
okay oh there's a guy around the flag
Aaron watch out a bad guy to be more
specific he was rolling with his flag
Defender load
out uhoh kill the guy with the
flag all right well he's jumping on them
trees first question is do we have
anybody playing defense because if we
don't that's a problem no turn
around
man I love that C4 so when somebody's
chasing you and you get that like spin
C4 maneuver down so good it is pretty
good pretty solid all right come to the
trees wait where is okay they've got a
bunch of dudes down there so watch
out bunch of dudes down there with
shotguns gu's going to try to get on
to here no I'm chasing an enemy oh that
guy behind
me I'm chasing the flag carrier I'm
coming up on him pretty far away from
Stu somebody needs to drop a Strider oh
gosh someone was up chasing me I feel
like all right I may need to go to my
flag Defender Ro which is that's one of
my it's one of my like pet peeves I
think they do have to balance it in this
game is um I don't think that flag
Defenders are awarded enough points to
encourage people to defend flags and I
think it's such an important part of a I
mean it's like half of a capture the
flag game that like you know the dude
sitting back
killing oh God that is awful killing
people who are capturing the flag should
be rolling in as many points as you know
the people running and capturing the
flag yeah you should be getting some I
mean like with hardpoint you are getting
some kind of uh you know bonus points
for hanging out near
the I've got the flag Samson I'm all
right I'm behind you
run trees save me I had a tree problem
I'm not going to lie there was a problem
with the trees it's not my fault coming
in hot for the
C
die die Sinister flag Stealers all right
all right we got an
escort see if I can clear out their flag
Defender before it comes
back I don't think so friendo
like do a celebratory kick in the back
of my teammate because I'm not actually
sure it was a
teammate you guys do that right they're
like just going to kick you real quick
Oh I thought I had the flag what
happened did you drop it did you not did
you ever even have it really uh-oh was
not
the swear that I had the
flag oh oh God thiss to kill me so bad
ah ha you're
doed it's important to say doed when you
mean doomed when talking about a Titan
because it's confusing and
hilarious
what God these oh my poor Strider oh no
oh no oh bad okay I'm just going to hide
among these trees all right let's check
out some of these other zip lines cuz
they seem to go to a lot of places on
this map you are up really high are we
checking out your feed or we just I just
got into a Titan so I'm going to go see
what I can do oh get Striders in my
face Bonk I say my chances of getting
out of here alive are slim but let's try
this anyway get big titan punched all
right get me out of here let's all
nuclear eject everybody nuclear eject up
into the trees where zip line is there a
zip line on this
side I don't oh no oh I missed that
entire tree
son of a bee oh I got chased down by so
obviously hitting these trees is a
little tricky because they're like round
and
[__] all right one of us may have to
switch over to flag Defender cuz we're
not doing so well I switched over to
enemy Titan
rodeo Oh
no got to kill him got to kill him hello
I have been slain
all right I'm hanging out by the
flyo
ready put a satle charge right there
under the desk oh
crapa take that grunt wait a
minute Auto
all right where you at Samson what's
going on trying to rescue my auto
Titan not very
successfully uh they've just taken our
flag but he's like way out super exposed
all right they're making a big old Titan
push crap they're definitely Titan
pushing the guy has hopped into his
Titan with a
flag my Titan just came down so close to
squishing him but he's off he's coming
in in a Titan all right I'm going to
ride come for R let's roll uh Which Way
chase the dude with the
ah well that was
quick why am I killing specters all
right let's see if I'm getting
protection from The
Shield like I supposedly should be oh
they've got the flag
again love God here take care of that
thing
a trees make this like a really cool
last Titan standing map you were saying
and I think I agree uh I'm going go over
to flag Defender for a little bit
my no I've been brutally slained oh so
horrible okay so I think one thing that
the capture the flag mode in this game
hasn't done yet is make it as fun for
the Defender as the attacker yeah um
since you know defending is half of
Capture the Flag you know I would really
like to try to see them rebalance it a
little bit and I think they started to
where the people you know hanging back
are rewarded for doing that important
job mhm yeah optional zero in the twitch
chat is agreeing with you saying defense
is so overlooked in so many online games
and people think defense is all camping
which of course has a negative
connotation but camping is a strategy it
has its time and place yeah I mean
that's you got to defend if it's just
everyone running around willy-nilly then
come on man what kind of strategy is
that oh can I pick up this gun I mean
you know people don't like camping I
would argue it's always related to
certain game modes but somebody somebody
camping and defending a flag is really
important in Capture the Flag as we saw
earlier with uh here comes the dude them
thwarting many of our
advances you got him he get him get him
yep
no did he get you from Beyond the gra
might might have been a dead man's
trigger nope it was
legit totally
gotcha but he didn't get the flag which
is the important
part that flag is Satchel charged up the
yinyang right I'm going to make a little
here Hees make a little
move I'm just running on the forth floor
by the way I just was working my way
through Gen 2 I finally
regen oh yeah have you so you've been
playing on the PC almost exclusively
right
yeah y he's got it oh
crap oh he's got it
ha I got him with I really like oh
freaking Dead Man's trigger so um I
really like using the mines in this game
offensively they're actually really good
they all they work similar to
grenades um they're good if you have the
flag and you're running for your life
mhm and you just throw them as you're
running on the ground see good job now
we got some good flag defense um oh it's
a bad guy oh he so bad help me if you
throw them on the
ground Samson he's down here yep I
killed his buddy um then the person
chasing you will run into the mines and
be stopped so it's it's like really
really
good yeah you just throw them on the
ground as you are as you're running all
right we need to get the guy guys's got
the
flag oh gosh jump above we either need
Triple Threat really we either need to
capture Oh Oh I thought I had my other
class out freaking satchel charges oh
God I hate them so
much a
nuts that was my fault I was there too
Aaron we all share responsibility in
this team
effort
crubs oh it's a little weird oh wow we
just got doubled I got a I got a little
hairy in there it's a little weird
playing so I I play normally on Xbox One
and I don't know if this is a recent
thing
or Aaron but
uh where where is he where oh he's
invisible he's dead got him uh no like
oh get the flag I can't return it in my
Titan I thought I could guy there's a
guy uh when you're playing in a party
with someone their uh thing is green get
out of my face like their name is green
so if you're used to looking
at BAM eat me eat it he's running with
it damn it
sorry dude I just got totally murdered
their name is green so like the color
recognition for me is was a little off
which is why you were near me and it was
freaking me out a little bit was not
good Titan sometimes it takes a second
for the like the red to show up they got
it they captured it all right let's put
one on the ceiling all right all right
we need to make some caps we do need
some caps for real
team what the freak make some C all
right so these guys are coming in off
these big trees yeah I mean you can that
is definitely the way to go you can go
across those trees across the entire map
particularly if you
have that that's a friendly like how did
he get onto that tree
though so they might be using stem also
if you're an attacker stem's a good way
to
roll oh my god there so many there
currently so many mines on our flag well
this dude's coming in hard that's hard
and hot at the same time hard oh so um
I'm gen two oh somebody just was smart
uhoh no they weren't that our oh my God
one of our guys just threw a
freaking go
go one of our guys just destroyed all of
our own minds what a
[__] was he just like all right get
back in there there's a guy with the
flag getting real got a man to kill
zealous with the
uh good job Team all right I'm just
going to leave my Titan
here didn't quite get
him all right these Titan battles I feel
like I should try to tip the scales on
one of
them so like I've been sitting here the
whole time defending right but I'm going
to probably come up at the bottom of the
scoreboard even though I've stopped
several flag runs mhm that's my that's
my problem you've been a very helpful
teammate where
they you'll not Dodge me at last time ha
I got
you
doom is your
fate
Rick you know sometimes you come in and
you make a move and then you're like
right in front of an enemy Titan and it
just doesn't go well for
you oh no oh no ran out of ammo at the
worst possible time all right well at
least I have shut down one of their
Titan
exits I'm going to go this is actually
like a really short
Corridor
between a nuts
it's totally right
here where do you think our evacuation
is going to be far away from where I am
in a bad place I'm going to lurk around
here I should probably wait for my Titan
to become available cuz otherwise I'll
probably die do some cold lurking while
my auto Titan engages enemies and I
shoot specters to draw attention to
myself for no reason so we
definitely lost lost by less that time
because we actually stayed back on
defense
his defense is hell of
important just going to hack some
Specter real quick this is an important
thing to do when the drop ship is coming
in five second wow look how many Titans
we've got right
now oh was a little further than I was
expecting oh God I don't think I'm going
to make it Aaron I'm going to jack right
into
it oh I'm coming oh I'm coming
yeah all right all right oh salvaging
some dignity I literally ejected through
the floor of the drop ship I probably
should have a broken neck of some kind
did did it catch you cuz usually I try
to I have to like go up and then come
back
down so did it catch you I came in
middle of the pack for stopping like
several flag runs five flag runs that
doesn't make any sense yeah you should
be getting some some little bonus I
guess for hanging out there but I guess
yeah then you know are you encouraging
camping blah yes it's Capture the Flag
somebody's supposed
to that's what camping Is Not a Bad
Thing inherently that's what's supposed
to happen all right uh check this out
I've been seeing a lot of
1050s there's a lot of people that have
hit level cap so do you think uh there's
going to be a raised level cap at some
point I'm assuming well I don't know
okay so the point of regen is to give
the game more
longevity um give people stuff to you
know continue earning after they've
already earned a ton of stuff I mean
give you an alternate play style so it's
fun if they increase the level cap
though without
adding like new equipment or anything I
don't see the point like I think you've
already sort of ground out to
1050 so what would be the point of
raising the level cap what whatever is
the point to give those super high level
people something else to to strive for
uh just a quick note here in the chat uh
in our actual our variety pack Lobby
here people are saying and this was to
my comment earlier when I couldn't
return the flag when I was in the Titan
yeah I don't think you can this these
guys are saying don't get into a Titan
with a flag it will drop so you can't do
that like quick Strider cap right from
the beginning you used to be able to see
is that new yeah you used to be able to
so I think that's a tweak and this is
the the third map in the Expedition DLC
coming up right now it's war games it's
actually a simulation so that's why
you're there's going to be all these
like I'm in a digital virtual world
squares around everywhere inspired by
the first training Mission I think yeah
by the tutorial and then I think there
are chunks of like Airbase Sierra and
other maps in here so that's at least
when I was reading about it it seemed
like it was sort of cobbled together
from
previous stuff I mean I remember reading
that this one and runoff I think were
both inspired by like original
development that didn't lead to Maps
they like they were the stuff that they
were playing with uh and then they made
the map set for the core release and
then they went back to some of the
original ones they were playing with and
made them into this DLC pack MH yeah and
that's interesting because you know oh I
at least always SP in before you
Samson yeah this does confirm in my mind
that some people definitely drop first
we're on the same Titan standing we're
on the same server same internet
connection and you're for some reason
dropping into matches before I am oh you
Al except you don't Dr into this match
you are simulating this match you just
Sim it up also on the training grounds
map what does it say something
Preposterous like 90% of Pilots die in
training yeah in the IMC the IMC would
lose every war if that were true because
they wouldn't have enough Pilots all
right so call call it out if you see
parts that you recognize this I don't
know oh wow check it look up look
straight up there's a uh simulation
ceiling that is really cool
whoa somebody's got the
balls who's got the
balls does is that what you call the
triple threat aon's got the triple
balls I'm crushing hell of specters over
here bro don't even worry about
it what up triple
balls uhoh made a terrible mistake oh I
can't get down there nuts nuts on a
butt all go triple balls wow let's go
I'm going to hide in this narrow
Corridor which can't go wrong at all for
me I'm sure got Triple B hey friend
can't hurt me
anymore I killed a grunt what what what
pilot over my head taking pilot fire
from my head
region no get out of my face oh it's bad
oh it's
bad what I'm not ejecting Oh Why didn't
it eject what the heck did you see that
oh I pulled the eject thing and he just
stood there holding it like I'm oh no I
didn't eject cuz I was actually getting
wailed on sometimes you just can't get
the E I didn't see the animation
properly I was just getting melee
killed everything is
okay oh no oh no a jack get out and
time uh-oh they're shooting at you Aaron
all right time to go to Rodeo
Drive this is my you're coming with me
load out come on don't go kill
NPCs all that was cool though actually
the NPC just like vaporized basically
yeah it's not good all right where'd you
go there he is all right I don't know if
I can make it that far without him
noticing me but we're going to try I
believe in your
Samson do it oh there's a man chasing me
nope what are you what's going on people
are shooting it's a war game why are you
shooting all
right uh-oh you're in the
smoke a lot of satchel charges you got
some extra when I roll Satchel I roll
there I roll lots of charges roll a
satchel full of satchel although I kind
of regret not not taking C4 with me cuz
C4 will kill a
strier
no a um C4 will kill a Strider if you
have extra take extra with you if three
mhm um one go will kill it all right
wait where's
my thought I had satchel charges on that
one maybe didn't get there in
time all right I kind of like that way
that I went earlier except no one's
coming with me now so I'm not going to
go Lone Wolf it on last Tian standing
last Titan standing more than any other
mode usually the team that that rolls
together
wins like if the other team splits up
and your team stays together it's
usually it's usually a win for your
team oh it's gone it's all gone bad
Aaron oh no I came in and he got the
punch off again oh shameful I wanted
that nuclear eject so
bad
go in for it ah P got away can he get
him so hard 40
mm uh I don't like this I'm surrounded
you never want to be surrounded in the
Titan no you certainly do
not Meanwhile my controller's just
entered Rumble mode and is constantly
rumbling all the time
oh no oh nulear get out of there get a
got nuke eject so yeah actually nuclear
ejection is one of the things that's
been uh updated in this patch so let
me wow look how high that guy got all
right so nuclear eject now does more
damage this is from the official patch
notes on titanfall.com nuclear eject now
does more damage against Titans
previously an atlas with full health
could survive a close- range nuclear
ejection atlas of course is the
mid-range Titan chassis uh given the
long tell the nuclear e has that bright
light
that we decided it is appropriate for it
to decimate Titans that are within the
blast
radius all right I need to not blow it
as much this time so for last Titan
standing mode you want your Titan to not
have Auto all right my you more or less
want to hang in there as long as humanly
possible possible my controller is
continuing to
rumble it's stuck on Rumble I'm going to
try to unplug it and see if it gets
better gr we can't play a man out it's
pegged on Rumble Samson I can't do it
deal with it deal with
it all right all right all right it's
cool it's cool I'm back in the
game look at you crouching in your Titan
crouching crouching will let you shoot
through keyholes sometimes that you
wouldn't otherwise be able to shoot
through okay I saw an explosion so
that's a good
thing a tiany type
explosion all right they do need a
better way for you they're coming around
the
flank they do need a better way for you
to communicate hey somebody get a pilot
off my back
yeah
not going to get me in that nject no
Siri oh but you are to come down let's
close in on these dudes pinch them oh
come on get them in the pinch damn
it I thought that I had the
uh punch all right yeah I didn't die
good job horribly I got a point and I
didn't yeah you think how do you feel
about their matchmaking system I think
it's improved a bit I mean it takes
longer to get into a match but I'm I'm
having fewer last Titan standing matches
where what do you say
Bonito B Bonito Gonzalez are stream
engineer in the back uh says matchmaking
is garbage bito does not approve of
matchmaking it makes him sad
are you doing it again no it's not it's
just cuz other Titans are rumbling
nearby you know if you were driving a
giant Mech it probably would Rumble yeah
sure but I'm not I'm on a freaking
couch
details yeah just come right at me
that's a good idea why don't you just do
that just come right at me keep coming
keep coming at me keep coming at me bro
are you baiting the
enemies
who's shooting me in the
back bad guys there like a Strider
somewhere around here doing Strider
things as they do this is like a big
open kind of don't
die don't worry Don't Die
Atlas it's not your
time
so the one thing I like doing with the
particle shield now that I didn't used
to do is when you drop the particle
shield and somebody charges you you
punch them back past it so it still
offers you protection
yep gotcha buddy you're going
down oh mo fuzz I'm I'm linking up with
you here we'll kill that guy and then we
win we win can do friend
wait is there one more NOP there's one
more y there he is careful there's a
pilot up on top up there suck my cluster
rocket I have definitely come around on
cluster Rockets I didn't used to like
them now I'm like all about them oh that
dude is Dash coring the hell out of
here you can run actually you can run
you can run really far cuz you're a
Strider and you might even be able to
hide a little bit he's trying to buy a
time so that the other guys will get off
of my freaking ride Man this ain't no
Rodeo squish some let play a game called
find The
Strider y there he is he's backed by the
spawn he just needs like one more tag
from me damage core oh yeah you got him
oh no someone someone else tagged him
but he's down
nice that's the thing with Riders
they're so good on the fly but if they
get pinned into a corner it's over so
fast
trouble trouble
trouble so I'm playing the supercharger
card in last Titan standing I tried
playing respawn it doesn't work in last
Titan standing doing what the respawn
burn card that'd be so dirty if that
works I've tried it it doesn't work that
would be pretty nasty so dirty fairly
decent is like running hard in
there
don't you try to Rocket barrage me
sucker how our right
flank bad
situation and gr flew so
far all right where B
situation oh yeah where are they it's
cool I got the one that was on our flank
looks like they're coming down the left
side looking for him oh there they are
think you're going to be in real tight
spot if you continue going over there oh
god oh
crabs not looking
good got to get out of here
man what is I'm taking insane amounts of
grunt fire down here I was standing on a
grunt's head and trying to kick him and
it wasn't all right don't go down that
Middle Lane there are a crazy number of
grunts just laying into
everybody careful there's a uh guy with
a plasma gun down there plasma don't
poke your head out unless you got a
shield
okay well he just made a dumb
move did you just overextend note
yourself when you have plasma do not
charge oh cuz he's got the plasma right
that's a ranged weapon man a ranged
weapon son wow look at these corridors
are crazy I would love to play another
dumb move love to play another game type
on
here just going to kick some
robots oh look at the there's this like
crazy wall run Highway over here not
only that but he charged an ogre you see
that right in front of your view that
blue Corridor that's just like a wall
run Corridor there's no bottom there's
no top but they're parallel walls and I
get this this orange one here that we
see on the spawn is also that you think
you can make it all the way through
probably charge rifle why
not try to get a little cheeky
here shall
I I don't know if that's a mistake but I
think my supercharge burn card's been
active for the last several rounds no I
mean your burn unless you've
died so they all went to the other side
of the
map we got a hustle wait where's that
coming
from yep they all flanked yeah I see
there's a bunch of them on the
left or at least there were
two
which side are they on they came after
us yeah which side oh I got vaporized
that was awesome I just totally watched
the pilot
vaporize I don't think so sucker I don't
think so so they all went
East man ain't no freaking Compass row
on this map there totally is look up at
the mini map on the upper left you can
totally see which direction you're going
look at me Mr Samson I know all sorts of
stuff about
directions I'm a cool dude sorry that
was totally uncalled for you're giving
me good information about the game I
don't know why I did it Aaron I'm
sorry all right Chris just kill him and
all is
forgiv I have abandoned my Titan I
haven't been in that thing this whole
match hey guess what I got a damage
Shield you probably shouldn't engage me
at range you probably should go hide
right now you probably should not stand
there and let me shoot you repeatedly
with 40 mm Cannon round why you keep
giving them tips man
jeez okay I guess their chat's not on or
anything like that so there's here
somewhere there's a pet up high
somewhere where's he at I'm up high do I
count all right let's stick together
just in case we get
rodeoed uh do are you over near
me I'm doing a lot of running around
wiing
me catch a ride with this guy come here
yeah one thing pretty crazy about these
Maps actually all the TitanFall Maps is
how much detail they put into the like
the what's outside the map like it's
really cool you can look at stuff off in
the distance there's like a whole city
here agreed a lot of times if you eject
you realize that there's a part of the
map that you would never see unless you
ejected unless you ejected
yeah all right that last Titan is dead
nice
Victory all right last place turn it
around wow Jay Lake who who would figure
that the Gen 10 level 50 player on our
team would have 12 freaking Titan kills
although on the other hand the other
team only had two Titan kills for their
1050 the regen is a double-edged sword
like I've had a couple of matches where
I like my team beat up on the other team
pretty heavily and then we got back to
the loading screen and it was like two
1050s on my team and nobody on their
team had even hit level cap like the
first time yep all right I just got my
Spitfire hey does anybody out there use
the Spitfire cuz I don't think it's very
useful for Killin Pilots I just had it
equipped because uh it's you know it's
totally good
for if you get the slammer attachment it
does like extra damage against Titans so
like this was a tip actually that Abby
Hep uh the community manager is she
Community manager anyways she's like
voice actress
like she's the model for like half of
these characters she works at respawn
entertainment she said during our PX
East event that like really that lmg
with the slammer is the only gun you
want equipped when you go into last
Titan standing matches that said I think
I mentioned this earlier on the stream
why I don't want to use that thing in
any other situation so that's why these
new mode specific loadouts are kind of
interesting and again those are not part
of the paid DLC they're just part of
their most recent patch I I like how
they split the difference with this DLC
so people who don't buy the DLC still
get a lot of the benefits of it just
minus the maps it's it's a very
fair kind of purchase or non-p purchase
that you we're g to play pilot Hunter
now
Aaron how do you feel about pilot Hunter
I would
like it's all right yeah it's better
than attrition I don't like attrition
because I I don't like modes where
people grind I feel like again like I've
said there's many different Shooters if
you give players a place to grind they
will grind and they will not necessarily
have fun doing it they will grind even
if it's like a self-loathing thing yeah
so I like pilot hunter in the sense that
it's more focused than a regular match
of attrition but and I I get it I get it
it's like a financial decision like not
including classic attrition would
probably be a bad move for a company oh
yeah no attrition is fun as hell man too
I wish somebody would have the balls not
to although a thousand cranes in the
chat hates attrition and astral stalker
is a span of fan of the Spitfire and
it's that terrible green that I can't
read Duncan Hornsby says pilot Hunter is
my favorite mode yeah I mean it's cool
cuz it's like attrition but there's a
like a larger strategic point to it but
yeah I just one of these days I wish
some developer would just have the balls
to not do a classic death not Death
Match yeah just do all modes well didn't
uh the multiplayer in like Far Cry 3 was
only that like four no there's totally a
death match that never mind it's just I
I think people will gravitate to the
mode they can grind out the most
experience on and that's almost always
an attrition Style
game oh I'm going to try to be sneaky
and use a ranged weapon with a
controller playing against people on the
PC so it couldn't oh this is not going
to go poorly at all I'm sure of
it all right want some
Pilots all right pilot get back into
that get
back oh I see you baby
I don't know once you unlock terrible
shooting oh my God once you unlock C4 I
don't see a point in not using it maybe
maybe C4 in mines but oh oh that was a
good
shot everybody's rolling suppressed in
Pilot Hunter since this mode is
important to kill
Pilots I mean I like pistol death from
above I like how in this game you know
that your load out does matter in a lot
of matches yep and your burn card
selection
matters what I don't like about
attrition is I think it's the one mode
that plays to the weaknesses of the 6v6
and this game like you can go through
entire matches without being able to
find people if they're all rolling
suppressed uh-huh I mean you'll find
somebody eventually but it just it
doesn't direct the flow very well
oh
no see you over there
pilot I'mma come for
you where did they go where did they go
George where they might switch over to a
supressed
class cuz you're just like lighting it
up yeah everyone knows instantly where
you are and flocks there no maybe you're
you should be a you're you're our decoy
I mean like I'm I'm even rolling
with Echo vision and I'm I'm like
honestly having a hard time finding Dead
Man's trigger oh yeah I got a kill with
the Dead Man's trigger oh I'm such a
jerk I'm having YY I'm a jerk like you
guys sorry what were you saying oh like
I'm rolling with Echo vision and I'm
having a hard time finding people right
now man I don't know about that whole uh
Echo Vision
situation oh you know what I read in the
uh one of the beginning match screens
which I didn't realize is you can jump
over Triple Threat shots yes that is
pretty
cool nope bad decision bad place y I
found somebody I think some was just not
awesome dead man trigger
yeah oh rude that is a rude skill to
have all right let's go whoever's Titan
this is before we die oh I
died
okay should I rematch it
nah okay pilot load out let's let's
throw in a
suppressor this what I really like about
this match map already and it's
something that I like about
um ah that demer not demer but the one
with the the ruined Hulk of a ship in
the middle of it Odyssey or something uh
is the multi-level Titan fights like you
can have Titans on different levels from
each
other uh you know battling it out and
not and like having to take into account
the elevation Advantage I think I made a
bad decision I just gave up my elevation
advantage to
live that guy go back up here no still
down
here oh it's not looking good for you
friendo oh God get out get
out oh Samson I'm using your Crouch move
oh God he came
down not going to not going to follow me
though C him not going to follow me into
my smoke of death knows what's good for
him oh yeah you got
him where is he though I went for the
prestigious
punch prestigious punch what is that I
like that term that's where you just
boost into them continually with your
Strider be advised your repl will be oh
you're getting chewed up bro that was my
guy oh yeah pilot kill I don't care if I
die oh God get out of
here all about the pilot
kills that suppressor doesn't help you
out a lot all right are you
insufficiently suppressed I'm suppressed
so it's interesting uh my favorite
weapon in this game is definitely the
car farts I got killed that's I got
kicked that's what I say when I get
kicked the thing with the car is that
it's not good stock you have to either
roll
balanc he was just standing right behind
me the car SMG which is like the second
tier let's do this let's rematch I just
rematched but the guy was already
dead oh he did a smart
thing yeah I don't know like the
suppressed
cars damage output is not
ideal
man I don't like this I got to get rid
of this load out got
splashed I know you want to kill me so
bad but now my friend is going to kill
you hopefully Oh no you're not you're
just going to keep trying to kill me H
you're dead oh you got dumbed I got to
get out of here they're going to come
after me no
kick aha those jump fights are awesome
the the crazy jump kick who can like
spin around stupid crazy back kick each
other
first those things are
ridiculous by the way if you
cloak don't use your jump Jets cuz they
totally give you away there is a perk
though that like helps you out
right I think there's a perk that's like
near invisibility it's one of the very
high level ones you unlock it at like
upper 40s maybe um I'm taking fire from
multiple
Titans this is not going to go well
where is this
guy I saw you down here but now you're
not here I wanted to party in the
sewer this is like I love these like big
open just like Titan fields at either
end of the map map oh I see you now yeah
these maps are large oh you're a
friendly no
fun have you mastered the uh the Bunny
Hop maneuver yet uh I can do it a couple
times I wouldn't say I'm a master of the
Bunny Hop maneuver oh God get away from
it the Bunny Hop uh that Aaron's
referencing is when you wall run in
Titanfall you run faster right uh so if
you come off a wall run to hit the
ground you're carrying a lot of momentum
you can't you can carry that momentum
through if you like just barely touch
the
ground uh like if you hop the instant
that your feet hit the ground you can
keep that momentum with you I'll try to
show you guys and you can actually chain
it several times there we go and then
boom like see I did that that first jump
I kept the momentum of my jump but of
course now I'm in like super awkward
jump mode oh
gosh I'm going to cat you all right I'm
just just going to shoot you the
oldfashioned way terribly 1% Health left
go switch to Aaron stream that was
terrible a I feel so ashamed here's my
advice don't
die you and your pro tips
Samson where is they where did they go a
too
invisible oh so one of the cool things
about uh counter to Echo vision is when
somebody cloaks you can't see them so
you get a false sense of security it's
pretty
cool why did you put down your thing and
then leave
it I totally have my Titan I should use
it oh crap I don't know what's going on
someone is destroying me I got to take
evasive
action oh get there get
there wow that was a big titan reain a
lot of Titans just cascaded on
down oh I was taking damage what I got
killed by
the wow were you in the wrong Titan's
Dome Shield I was so I got into my Titan
and I just got killed by the other Titan
Dome Shield I didn't even know that
could
happen well you like you get what
happens like you get D you can get
domed good job Titan wow he hit it
that's funny it hey we did Victory we
did a victory Aaron good job Auto Titan
how do you give your auto Titan a
bone who's a good Auto Titan yes he is
we're going to go shoot down this drop
ship or what
yeah uh rule thumb is if there are three
Titans alive on the enemy team don't
bother getting in the drop ship because
three Titans can easily destroy a drop
ship
just to say this drop ship is going to
be a bad scene for all these dudes we
all involved so what is a a good way to
do it is sometime but like even if
you're a pilot right you want to get in
there cuz you can get a bonus but so
boom like you throw a cluster rocket
near the like
closest
uh what in so match just ended before
the ship got destroyed or left we killed
all the combatants yeah
all right so here's my tactic right the
drop ship comes in even if I know the
drop ship's going to get destroyed I
still go for it you get an next you get
an experienced bonus that unless you're
going to dome a Titan in the short
amount of time you have left you're
probably not going to beat by just
getting into the drop ship so you get in
there people want to go to the drop ship
so if you've got one of the cluster
missiles you shoot that near the like
the most the the path of least
resistance to the drop ship and then you
kill the guys on the way to the drop
ship while you're shooting the rest of
the drop ship I usually prefer to just
hang
out down let's go you quiet down all you
guys quiet down so I usually prefer to
just hang out if there's three Titans
and we lose I'll just stay and fight
enemy
Titans because I don't see a point in
dying in a drop ship explosion It's So
Glamorous Aaron everyone remembers your
name for all
eternity amped Hemlock go away I don't
like you dead need to use my burn cards
more what are we playing next hardpoint
all
right I think I unlocked a new scope for
this thing which I'm totally not gonna
use uh yes I am going to use that that
looks
better why do these people keep getting
unmuted all right so this will probably
be our last match uh of the stream fin
get to play this oh my goodness quiet
down
everybody uh this is the expedition DLC
it's $9.99 uh you can get the season
pass for
$24.99 uh which is I think five bucks
off if you want if you're planning to
buy all three planned DLC they're
dropping three Maps per is that what
they're saying what they're doing this
one so I'm assuming that's going to be
the case pretty standard yeah um yeah it
seems like the stuff like new modes
there has that do you know if that new
mode last tight and standing 2v2 has2 I
it might have been a private match thing
I'll have to go back and check yeah I
feel like that's the opp of what I
wanted I think I wanted like 12 V12 12
V12 you're
crazy I don't know maybe there out there
who will get pleasure out of 2v2 and
it's going to like eventually just be a
quick draw mode where two Titans just
take Five Paces in
turn I don't see a point in making the
player count Lower I like
it all right I'm going to roll with a
smart pistol because why not sorry Bob
Jones we can't play all day uh we are
actually going to put together a quick
PR video preview uh based on our time
playing this DLC uh that I'll post by
the end of the day today you're driving
first why driving first listen Aaron I
gotta you know I got to get in here get
in on
indoor I'm going to roll Titan this time
or roll
Strider this map has is has the like
most impressed me I just had no idea
this forest was going to be this
big so I don't have the silencer on my
smart pistol I have the enhanced
targeting which is probably going to be
I don't know not super good for me I
don't know we'll see how it
works I'm to go farm some
grunts what wow that dude oh smart
pistol that makes a lot more
sense what going on who's beeping I am
why are you beeping so much I killed a
grunt aren you proud of me all right I'm
going to follow some of my
friends
aha I's dead what is my thing cloak I
should have
cloaked get up there get
ah under get over there
and dead hang up by Bravo in this little
what how did that titan fall down there
you see where this Titan just fell
through this freaking hole right into
the middle of this place agressive
that's crazy we got to explore also like
a lot of the zip
lines I'm going take this zipline
actually I should not do
that
nope that was bad I don't want to use a
smart pistol anymore give me SMG please
wow who are you and why are you shooting
so
good hold the grunt that's right oh yeah
you're going down Budd he helpless
against
me oh yeah pinch your maneuver Samson
they're shooting me there's another guy
around there a shotgun guy get him
avenge me I did oh thank you he tried to
donkey you're Prince you're an absolute
Prince uh so it looks like this like B
is a point you definitely won't be able
to capture with
Titans but I'm wondering about running
they're running in on C on C all right
so like I got
here and like Bunny Hop between these
trees Bunny Hop isn't the
correct oh yeah tree I'm freaking Edward
Kenway up in this
[__] like
C4 oh man I got dead man charged like C4
so much dead man h no tails except for
when they charge you actually B probably
can be captured by TI that got
totally couple of these guys have died
trying to kick
me all right I got a good run going with
the
car nice get me out of here I'm happy
with all right
so I feel like the eject has changed
because that's the second time that I oh
look he did it again he tried to catch
me so I died last time that happened
what do you
mean um clarify SS he dropped his Titan
right next to my Titan uhuh and the
bubble Shield caught me when I got into
my Titan and killed me which seems like
like something they should
patch you rodeoed his Titan last time is
what Bonito is saying cuz the Titans
were so close you went for the enemy
rodeo and is that what happened yeah no
I thought I saw myself get in the hand
though iwitness accounts are notoriously
unreliable Aaron that's
true uh so what I'm saying is I went to
nuclear regy
twice after my ship was doomed and there
was a guy close by within range of
punching but I was pretty sure that I
got the three Taps to eject myself which
you know then goes just starts up that
nuclear eject sequence however in both
of those cases I really feel like oh
where where's that dude I really feel
like the Titan was able to interrupt
with a punch
my go there was able to interrupt my
Nuclear eject with a punch in a way that
was not possible before um nuclear
object does not trigger if you get
manually
killed dead man oh no I didn't get I got
the smart
pistol right but I'm saying once you've
activated the nuclear eject sequence by
pressing the eject button three times to
fulfill the eject require
the animation was uninterruptible before
is what like you even if even like once
you had hit that point you couldn't be
interrupted with a melee but I think
that happened to me twice during the
stream I've definitely noticed also what
just happened yeah come
on so it's weird actually since they
instituted the matchmaking system and it
I don't know if it's related to it but I
have noticed more bugs I think they're
still some of their what do you mean
like what kind of bugs things like this
like crashes taking longer to get into
matches weird stuff happening I think
there's a little bit of instability in
some of the recent patches that they're
probably going to have to work out
little bit of fun
stability that was bad sorry uh all
right that one ended abruptly and
unsatisfactorily I feel like that's a
crap way to end a stream so for you
folks we'll play another round otherwise
we just go back and do our jobs but
no for you for the people Aaron the
people also for the robots for the
robots we're not robot worth noting this
doesn't this uh has not ComEd
out this one this does not come out for
the Xbox 360 for like another couple
weeks it's only available for the three
for the Xbox One and PC currently we're
both playing on PC
currently no it's it's another devel
veler right that's doing the 360
blueo is the name of that
developer play Blue
Point all right uh I'm excited to
actually play this on a different mode
than last Titan standing so you get to
use those uh the Run routes in the
middle of the map that we were talking
about yeah those are very fast ways to
get from place to place so we're going
to have to using your butt Jets check it
out all right
capture the flag and then we'll finish
up the stream thank you guys for
watching you know one of the
things Ryan Cher and I were talking
about something they could add to this
game which would be fun would be is if
your Titan could pull you out of its
chest and throw
you so instead of you ejecting out or
how awesome would that be if your Titan
could just take you and like hug you
like a football and you just could throw
yourself like up onto whatever ledge or
some crap I would accept that and like
in one of your perk slots that would be
pretty
hilarious that or they can accomplish
the same thing by giving you a perk
where your jump Jets could have one huge
boost you sort of charge up a jump jet
boost like a charge jump I mean well you
kind of I mean they have enhanced
parkour and wall running as a perk or as
a kit uh is that do you think that also
affects I'm going to all right here we
go let's do this I'm going to play
defend a little bit I'm going to try to
why did I fall off that nope that's not
why weren't you better to me
wall this is where people are going to
come no that's why standing is not a
good
idea no I see you baby I didn't wall
hang tried to wall hang wall hang didn't
happen all right let me uh let's mine up
our flag quite a lot all right come at
me me
bro good job good job flag carrier
person is enemy enemy pilot that's just
running around over here willy-nilly is
there interior here yes y guy down
below all right I'll play a little bit
of Defense if you want to go make runs
on the
flag playing defense too man we're
holding it down all right yeah I should
probably do that we should probably mix
it
up
okay all right back myself into a corner
so I am using unlimited look there's a
hollow tank oh come on Hollow tank what
are you even doing render fully
lame all right I'm going to go ahead and
try to do some blanky tank Maneuvers
that's a term don't don't question
it um so I'm using the burn card that
gives me unlimited mind
cheap I don't care I don't care if it's
cheap hey it's a burn card baby it's a
burn card it's the game it's making me
win it's all in the game will be ready
in seconds grunts yeah I'm not even
trying to kill you right now one point
for sneaky
sneaks all right Aon what do you think
do I need to like mine the oh wow never
mind I just need to go help our buddy
outy
sneaky sneaks for the win goty flag all
right I'm coming down the blue Corridor
run in my general direction I'll cover
you somebody's chasing you I'll get him
oh there's a watch it there's a
uh there's a Titan trying to shoot you
oh I just made it did you see that dude
through a satel charge in the windows
coming right in my
face it hell yeah that person is so
upset they were just a second too
late that is a kill cam oh
shame put on my charge rifle here in
case anyone all right I'm going to mine
the ceiling I'm just going to be a total
bastard and hope those go off total
bastard Aaron Samson is my goal in life
there was a ghost did you guys see that
that was frightening bastard MC Samson I
totally see a guy running in circles
there he
is you die he
died what
what what happened s oh I died that was
my own mind that was my mind I died you
mind yourself uh they set off they set
off the
mine and it killed me cuz they were the
extra powerful sweet couch oh yeah
everybody just lounge around and look at
the empty wall I guess that could be a
TV
Haya no kicking
TVs
oh bad job Samson someone's coming in
the blue way yep yep that happened I
need to go back to my defending class he
let rematch it
rematch
oh ha I rematched it see that's where
the burn cards come in that was nice
work rematched it drop drop oh and then
then they came
back all right let's get back to my flag
Defender man I like these uh
personalized Loadout slots per mode are
you going to D it up Samson yeah keep
keep trying to cap I'll just play
D
although they're starting to get smart
and actually
play play some D they're actually
starting to do what you're supposed to
do which is
uh throw
um explosives in on the
flag
I've got the flag clear on they're on me
they're on my tail they're behind
us oh God everything going so slow
careful there's a guy there's a guy in
there let me take care of him first go
over
there right to your face return that
thing get it get in here Yeehaw teamwork
making the DreamWork oh God there's a b
guy where'd he go where'd he go where
did he go George where did he go oh man
look at this corner this is a good
camping corner right here did you find
yourself a camp camp out I'm proud of
this camp out little campsite not going
to lie look at you up there nice this is
a campsite to be proud of I mean if
you're going to Camp I see you coming
back or somebody came
back see be a running train on these
guys I just saw Titan bits run through
our uh live cap
site come on in get I'm standing right
next to you in all the ax
a they're going to get our flag couldn't
stop him in time they're not going
anywhere with
it careful nuke yeah that's me
yeah good nuke good nuke sir I returned
oh
I'm coming back in a
Titan who's punching me hey you're rude
quit punching me and your mother tell
you not to
hit get out of here Auto Titan no one
likes
you all right I'm just going to go run
my Titan over
here
so uh before I got into combat what I
was trying to say was uh they are smart
in throwing in Ark mines before they
cap which is what you should do just oh
I almost made it out you should expect
you got you you should attack that's
what I was just that's what I just did I
blew up like three satchel charges
before going in there of course that
also announces your presence to your
enemy yeah it's getting blown up maybe
like throw the satel charge in One
Direction and then infiltrate another
Direction um or use Echo Vision like I
am I mean that'll just tell you where
everybody's at oh
no oh what what who did
that sometimes oh was that them yeah he
was smart he did a smart
thing they're getting smart too
where did he come up from what did what
are they doing are they doing the mine
thing that you're saying
yeah oh they captured our flag hey good
for them oh aren't they
Plucky Plucky little
underdogs not getting shut out GG guys
they're getting smart about um bombing
the
flag
no go down go
down son of a
be what was that gackle of delight oh no
that's not what I wanted to do I dropped
my Titan and then try to get into
another bad guy
Titan uh I just shotgun a flag Grier
pretty hard not going to lie that guy
really took it took it took a real mean
shotgunning
Victory is our oh gosh I'm getting
destroyed that Titan wanted to kill me
pretty bad and he did good go good going
Titan
a charge rifle you so
badly oh
yep oh think about the place where
they're going to go probably not a good
place for me to be down
there they do have a fair amount of
Titans that can be taken care of no oh
I've been I've been slain Aaron do us
proud oh looks like they're going to get
away with this one yep they got too many
Titans and I don't have
enough although nuclear ejecting is an
awesome tactic in the end of matches
underneath the uh underneath drop ship
yeah like you might not be able to
drop your Titan on the drop ship anymore
but you sure as hell can still run up in
nuclear J you think that nuclear still
damages
it I don't see why it wouldn't we could
test it what of our dudes got 26 pilot
kills holy
crap that's a lot also that makes me
suspicious ah suspicion aside I came in
middle of the pack I stopped almost
almost every flag run that they did on
our flag up top middle of the pack
middle of the
pack yep oh I got a new pilot
customization slot for playing Capture
the Flag I got assorted burn cards
hooray a fine assortment of burn cards
behold some of our finest burn cards
here for your perusal all right folks uh
that's the TitanFall Expedition DLC the
first pack of three maps for Titanfall
uh for the Xbox One and PC $9.99 if you
get season pass it's $25.99 and then you
get the two other packs that are coming
uh what else we got uh there's also a
patch so a lot of the stuff we were
talking about any of the like balance
tweaks or mechanic stuff that is across
the board just a patch you update it's
like customiz slots should be there
without DLC yep um your mode specific
slots all that stuff being able to
rename all of your custom your custom
classes yeah uh it's just those three
new maps swamp land the aka the forest
Moon Endor totally Endor uh runoff the
multi-layered sewage treatment disaster
place which kind of cool for Titan
combat smelly bit fun and that one war
games which I actually really liked I
thought that was some pretty good flow
Capture the Flag wise uh so yeah that's
our stream I'm Chris Waters Aaron Samson
saying thanks for watching take a look
later on today for our more coverage on
Titanfall and uh have a great day thanks
for joining us see you later
bye